it was a lot of fun but obviously going
straight from work to getting married to
back to work is absurd
Missy may not have had time for a
honeymoon but her hard work is
definitely paying off as FBI just
received an early season two renewal you
would of course one of the producers
called Peter and all he said was Bravo I
was like teacher hello
he's like congratulations I was like
okay because season two and I was like
okay that's great
okay this is a lot of work and that's
immediately it went straight to the
reality of it which is I've never been a
part of something that got picked up and
was so supported right away and it's
great to be a part of that hey you guys
okay
[Music]
you never quit
even when the mission went sideways he
never quit I'm always really interested
in character stuffing and getting to
know the people who are the FBI agents
so that's awesome you have to have more
seasons to do that really for me that's
it I mean procedurally we're always
going to be tackling some of the biggest
issues and it's interesting but I really
like the heart stuff and when you have
amazing co-stars to work with it makes
going to work that much better it's
funny though cos Zico started as soon as
we met he's like we're best friends I'm
your best friend but I was like Zico but
we spend more time together than me and
Tom so but for Missy putting on that FBI
uniform means one thing I'm a badass now
I think what I really love is that every
time I walk into a room I feel like I
have a lot of power and I don't have to
push anything and I don't have to be
strong I don't do anything because I
already have an ability to get the
information that I want to get and solve
things and that's really fun to play